[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know the beauty of this job when you
do a national job
a national show
that i can pick and choose what i want
to talk about
and i can bounce around it could be the
transfer portal it could be antonio
brown it could be aaron rodgers it could
be the snow that we had last night
if you're a local
host of a show
sometimes you can't get away from
something like you have to talk about it
and uh we thought it would be fun to
have uh tom krasnicki on he does the
local radio show in tampa our great
radiophilia wdae
ronnie and t craz they got off they do
the show prior to ours and i thought
it'd be uh good to have tom on to give
us what that local perspective is of
what's gone on this past season and tom
joins us now tom thanks for joining us
first of all if i would have told you a
week ago
that this was going to play out with
what happened with antonio brown you
would have said what
i would have been surprised dan because
this has been antonio brown's pattern of
behavior the last three or four years
and as you mentioned yeah on our show we
got a lot of buccaneer fans now there
were some fans that were pushing back at
us saying antonio brown i don't care
what goes on off the field he's a
dynamic playmaker he can help us win a
super bowl so i don't care about what
happens off the field those fans
presumably enough are not nowhere to be
found right now obviously
um what bothers you about this story
whether it's the buccaneer side of this
bruce arians or antonio brown like is
there something that is
doesn't match up correctly here
dan for me it's antonio brown in what he
did last weekend leading up to that jets
game i mean who would have thought that
the most scoring he would do
was off the field last weekend the night
before the jets game rather than the
jets game itself but
him complaining about the lack of
targets is not really surprised because
he did the same thing in pittsburgh a
couple of years ago that led to his
departure and he was the second most
targeted receiver at the half of the
game against the jets so i'm not sure
why he would sit there and start
complaining and then reportedly he went
to the buccaneers and wanted them to
guarantee some of his incentives i mean
you've got the audacity to try and pull
that car with the buccaneer so
his erratic behavior is all over the
place and that's a guy who i think is
crying for help
what are the reviews of bruce arians and
how he's handled it this week
i think very good i think bruce has
handled it about as well as you can i
mean he couldn't say much earlier in the
week to us by the zoom calls because
lawyers were getting involved and to be
quite honest with you dan i don't think
bruce wanted antonio brown here in the
first place and the only reason why he's
here as you know is because tom brady
still carries a lot of influence within
the buckingham organization so bruce
relented and said okay we'll bring him
in we're going to hold our breath and
hope that he stays on his best behavior
and it was going well there for a while
and then
the fake cobot vaccine card controversy
came to a head and then it didn't take
long after that for antonio brown to
melt down again but tom i'm curious i
don't understand this if antonio brown
is is claiming about his targets at
halftime he's going to check out of the
game but then he does need surgery on
his ankle how
how do you get these targets if you're
not capable of playing because you need
surgery on your ankles some there
something doesn't add up here
well that was his side saying yeah the
ankle was all jacked up but he was not
in a boot he was not under you know
crutches after the game he was seeing
courtside at a brooklyn nets game the
very next night so that's what his side
was claiming the buccaneers claimed that
he was cleared to play he was out there
he was playing and then for some reason
he didn't want to go back into the game
and as bruce erin said yesterday you
know what get the blank out of here
you're done
because antonio brown says that he gave
the throat slash i
i mean my thought is
you know i just think he's pointing to
get out of here and he viewed it as a
throat slash but this is what abs ammo
has been in in all of his different
stops
but there's a moment i i brought this up
to my audience tom the last couple days
it's i think six minutes and 36 seconds
to go in the third quarter and tom brady
walks down the sidelines and they they
show this on camera and he's
basically checking in with antonio brown
who i think is basically checking out
before he takes off his pads and you
could almost see brady resigned to the
fact that i lost him like this guy is
has checked out i i don't know if brady
has i want to know what he said to
antonio brown in that situation because
it was right after that
where i think bruce wanted him in the
game he said i'm not going in he said
get out of here
and brady's on the field
well think of it this way dan i was
thinking about this the other day on our
show here's tom brady a guy who vouched
for antonio brown not once
but twice he invited him into his home
took him under his wing no listen he's
misunderstood i'm gonna take care of
this guy he's gonna help us win and here
was antonio brown late in the third
quarter down 24-10 he just gets up and
leaves tom brady and he leads his
teammates high and dry and give tom
brady a lot of credit because he's like
okay he's gone
let's go to war with the guys that he
has that that he has and with two
minutes left and no timeouts calmly
marches him down the field and scores a
touchdown to beat the jets i mean that's
what kind of competitor and what kind of
focus that tom brady has and and it's
that's something that we really haven't
shined the spotlight on that brady
just no
antonio brown just
committed career suicide in tampa tom's
got to get on the field and no timeouts
go 90 yards and win this game
and you know degree of difficulty as at
a pretty high level let's look at bigger
picture how how dangerous is this team
as we get to the post season
if they get healthy dan they could be
very dangerous now the big questions are
levante david leonard fournette shaq
barrett is not going to play this sunday
they hope he's ready for the start of
the playoffs so they can get these three
guys back in healthy mike evans is now
healthy from his hamstring which is a
great sign but i think they're locked
and loaded and they can take down anyone
in the nfc including the packers now i
would have green bay as the clubhouse
leader because
nobody in the nfl has a better home
field advantage in the playoffs than
green bay and they're going to get some
healthy guys back namely jayer alexander
david bakiri and maybe zadaria smith so
i think green bay has the edge but with
the buccaneers getting healthy dan
hopefully
you can't bet against tom brady
tom great to talk to you have a good
weekend maybe an uneventful week do are
you hoping for some you know i was just
talking about the content factor of i i
don't have any horse in the race here
but you give me content i loved antonio
brown here uh are you looking for a very
simple
methodical
get a win against carolina game or are
you looking for a little more drama i'm
looking for more drama dan listen
unfortunately with antonio brown out of
town to quote cousinette from christmas
vacation
he's the gift that keeps on giving he
does yes he does thank you tom my best
to the folks at wda-ing
that's a tom krasnicki uh he hosts the
show ronnie and t craz that uh the show
that precedes ours